vamos a ganar esta carrera solo miren lo
que ha observado desde lo que ha
sucedido desde ayer hace 24 horas
estuvimos detrás y estuvimos frente al
señor y ahora estamos adelante y vamos a
ganar ese estado hace 24 horas estuvimos
detrás en pensilvania y vamos a ganar
pensilvania y ahora estamos en la
delantera
ganamos ganando en arizona ganando en
nevada de hecho nuestra diferencia se ha
duplicado en nevada estamos en camino
con más de 300 a camino a 300 votos
electorales y miren los números ahora
vamos a ganar esta carrera con una clara
mayoría de la nación que está detrás
nuestro hemos recibido más de 74
millones de votos
voy a repetir eso 74 millones de votos
eso es más que cualquier otro otra dupla
presidencial que cualquier otra otra
presencia en la historia de eeuu y eso
sigue creciendo
hemos ganado estamos ganando alto por
más de 4 millones de votos un margen que
sigue creciendo una de las cosas que me
enorgullece particularmente es lo bien
que lo hemos hecho en todo eeuu y vamos
a hacer los primeros demócratas en ganar
en edición en 24 años vamos a hacer los
primeros demócratas en ganar georgia en
28 años y vamos y reconstruimos el muro
azul en medio del país que se es bueno
no hace cuatro años en pensilvania
michigan wisconsin el corazón de esta
nación ahora sé que viendo estas cuentas
de votos en televisión parece ser lento
por lento que va puede ser sorpresivo
pero no se olviden que esto no son sólo
números estos representan votos y ago
los votantes hombres y mujeres que
ejercieron el derecho fundamental a que
sus voces fueran oídas y lo que se hace
claro con cada hora es que ese número
récord de estadounidenses de todas las
razas y religiones eligieron el cambio
sobre más de lo mismo nos han dado un
mandato para lograr la acción sobre el
cobit sobre la economía sobre el cambio
climático el racismo sistemático han
dejado claro que quieren que el país se
reúnan no que se siga desmoronando
la gente ha hablado más de 74 millones
de estadounidenses hablaron con mucha
fortaleza por nuestra dupla pero
mientras esperamos estos resultados
graves quiero que la gente sepa que no
estamos esperando hacer el trabajo y
empezar el proceso ayer la senadora
gervis y yo nos unimos con grupos de
expertos en salud pública y sobre la
crisis económica que ese país está
enfrentando la pandemia como ustedes
también conocen
se está haciendo cada vez más
preocupante todo el país los casos se
han incrementado y ahora se cree que
podemos llegar a un pico y ver 200 casos
al día siempre la cuenta se acerca esto
son 240 mil personas muertas sillas
vacías en las cocinas y en los comedores
de todo estadounidense nunca seremos
capaces de medir todo este dolor y toda
la pérdida todo el sufrimiento de tantas
familias y ahora sabemos cómo se siente
perder a alguien
quiero que ellos sepan que no están
solos nuestros corazones están rotos con
los de ustedes queremos quiero que todos
sepan desde el primer día no vamos a
poner este plan en acción para controlar
el virus no podemos salvar las vidas que
ya se perdieron
pero podemos salvar muchas vidas más en
los meses que vienen clase n ahora
jarvis sus recuperando su recubrimiento
se está demorando
es por la falla de más de 20 millones de
personas están empleadas millones de
personas están preocupadas por lograr el
dinero de la renta y poner el dinero
para la comida no su plan económico
se enfocará en crear un camino para una
recuperación fuerte
miren sabemos que hay tensiones fuertes
pueden ponerse fuertes después de una
elección tan ruda como la que tuvimos
pero es necesario recordar que hay que
mantener la calma y la paciencia hay que
dejar que el proceso se desenvuelva a
medida que se hace el escrutinio en
todos los votos estamos probando los de
nuevo así como lo hemos hecho por 240
años que la democracia funciona sus
votos serán contados no me produjo no
importa lo mucho que la gente intente
detener esto no permitiré que suceda
la gente el pueblo 0 y 2 nuestro viaje
es hacia una unión más perfecta y sigue
avanzando en eeuu tenemos perspectivas
fuertes y hay desacuerdos fuertes eso
está bien
los fundadores sabían que esos
enfrentamientos son inevitables en una
democracia y sabían que son saludables
son la señal de un debate vigoroso de
perspectivas que se defienden con
fortaleza debemos reportar el propósito
de la política
que es acabar con la que acabar la
guerra el propósito de la política del
trabajo de la nación es acabar con las
llamas del conflicto pero resolviendo
problemas garantizar la justicia darle a
todos una oportunidad justa
y mejorar las vidas de las personas
puede que haya oponentes puede que
seamos oponentes pero no somos enemigos
somos estadounidenses sin importar por
quien usted haya votado yo estoy seguro
de una cosa la vasta mayoría es los 150
millones estadounidenses que han votado
quieren sacar estas dudas de la política
no vamos a estar de acuerdo en muchas
visiones pero podemos estar de acuerdo
en ser cívicos uno con el otro
- hay que poner la ira y la organización
atrás hay que reunirnos como nación y
sanar y esto no va a ser fácil tenemos
que intentarlo mi responsabilidad como
presidente será representar a toda la
nación y yo quiero que ustedes sepan que
nuestro que trabajaré tan fuerte por los
que votaron en contra de mí así como por
los que votaron por mí ese es el trabajo
ese es el trabajo este se llama el deber
de cuidar a todos los estadounidenses
tenemos problemas serios con los cuales
debemos lidiar está el cob y está la
economía la injusticia racial el cambio
climático no tenemos mucho más tiempo
por perder
guerras partidistas saben más que eso
tenemos una oportunidad tan increíble
para construir el futuro que queremos
para nuestros hijos y para nuestros
nietos yo he dicho en muchas ocasiones
nunca he sido más optimista sobre el
futuro de esta nación
no hay ninguna razón por la cual no
podamos poseer el siglo 21 debemos
recordar quiénes somos y somos los eeuu
de américa no ha habido nada
absolutamente nada que no hayamos podido
hacer que no hayamos podido lograr o que
no hayamos podido hacer juntos y espero
estar hablando de ustedes mañana quiero
agradecerle a todos y que dios los
bendiga a ustedes y que dios proteja a
nuestras tropas buenas noches
[Aplausos]